go live
hi everyone welcome to another episode
of science and technology q a for kids
and others and i see that we
have a bunch of questions left over from
last week
[Music]
let's see we have one question from a
toure here
any tips on how to make nice
presentations
you know i've been making presentations
a really weird way for a really long
time
which is that i do live coding
and that's really something made
possible by our whole world from
language technology
stack because i can like
type a small amount of code in and have
something interesting happen
and i guess i know our language well
enough that there's a decent chance
the code i type in will actually work um
i think that from what i can tell
that's a very effective way to make
presentations
because people can then actually take
away something practical which is they
could type this code into
and usually when i do a presentation in
modern times i'll create
a you know wolf notebook uh of
which is mixture of uh you know code and
it's generating all kinds of pictures
and maybe i'll type a little bit of text
in but mostly
it'll be code generating pictures and
then i'll say publish to cloud
and i'll get a version of that notebook
that's been put in the cloud
and you even nowadays get this little qr
code
that people can scan if it was an in
person uh event
um that they can then get immediate
access to that notebook
so it's like you've got the notes from
the talk
in not just the static notes but also
something where you can go in and start
changing the code
and so on you can do that from a phone
or from a computer or whatever else
so it's kind of an interesting mechanism
for for making presentations
i would say that uh for me
the um um you know i i
suppose i should admit a few things
about presentations that i make
one thing that is always bad for me if i
prepare too long in advance
it will be a worse presentation now you
know i must have given thousands and
thousands of presentations in my time
so it's it's some uh
you know i have a decent amount of
experience um but what i found is you
know if i like oh i'm going to prepare
this
three days in advance et cetera et
cetera et cetera by the time i actually
get to give the presentation
i've kind of i'm not in the same mood as
when i prepared it i kind of i'm like oh
what
what did i mean by this note that i made
you know what what what was i talking
about
and it's very uh it doesn't it doesn't
flow very well whereas if i'm
like uh you know i think about what i'm
gonna do just before i give the
presentation i'm kind of in the same
mood and i'm ready
and um uh i'm kind of uh you know and
i'm kind of
all thinking about it and so on and then
it works much better
i mean for me one of the issues is
if i'm uh you know the more i know the
audience
the more i understand something about
the audience the better a presentation
i'm going to be able to make
um and there have been a few times you
know i always keep track of the times
when the just been as far as i'm
concerned an utter disaster
like you know presentations i prepared
and then like if it's an in-person event
i remember one from many years ago now
in-person event where i'm i'm physically
there and i'm meeting a bunch of the
audience and
you know the the night before something
some grand sort of keynote thing or some
such other thing
and i'm like oh my gosh this is the
wrong
talk for this audience but i prepared
the whole thing
and so it's like well i guess i get to
give it and
yeah it was the wrong talk for that
audience and i think that the um
uh you know so i think that's a that's a
relevant thing
i think that um uh for me
it's always some uh
you know i guess i i do best when i'm
not
talking about but i'm not saying the
exact same thing i've said a bunch of
times before now
having said that i've ended up uh
talking about you know
there's some topics that i've ended up
talking about over and over and over
again
because it's like they're important it's
always fun to see people
you know i understand them for the first
time um
but uh and i think it is the case that
one gets a little bit better at
explaining the same thing over again
you know a thing that i've done in terms
of giving presentations you're asking
this question so i
try and give an answer i mean i i'm
really not you know i've actually never
used powerpoint for example i sometimes
use
our uh presentation system and and well
from notebooks where you can
you know interact with the presentation
as well as just
put up a slide but but this idea where i
put you know where people put a certain
amount of
text from of what they're going to say
up on the screen for people to see i i
don't i've never done that
um i i've uh i i don't know i'm not sure
it's necessarily a bad thing
but maybe i haven't prepared enough in
advance what my
what precisely i'm going to say um to be
able to do that i the thing that i also
tend to do is i tend to have a
a slide picker usually i'm using
multiple screens
um and uh you know even when i'm doing
an in-person talk
i'll have two screens so one is a slide
picker and one is what i'm actually
showing
um and potentially typing live code into
when i'm giving the presentation and so
what will typically happen is i'll have
a slide picker
where i have a bunch of of uh
collections of
of um well they're usually notebooks um
where i'm i'm clicking a particular uh
particular slide and as i go through the
the talk i'm giving i haven't
necessarily arranged those slides
in order beforehand um you know i i i'm
just picking them out in real time
from these sort of slide pickers and
that means that if i
decide to change the order in which i do
things in the talk
it's like it's okay because i'm just
picking out a different thing and then
when it comes to
to q a it's it's uh then
then it's great because it's like
somebody asked a question and like
oh yeah i've got a slide here boom here
it is up on the screen
and that works that works really well
now you know a few times when i've been
giving
i always find it much more difficult to
give short talks than long talks maybe
people
who have been uh coming to these live
streams can
can recognize the reasons for that i i
find it much easier to kind of explain
things long form
than i do to say oh yeah compress it
into two sentences you know
what's the sound bite so to speak um but
there are some times when i've been
sometimes somewhat reluctantly agreed to
give sort of the short
you know the the 18 minute talk or
whatever
and where i'm like i've got to compress
a whole bunch of stuff into this into
this uh
fairly short amount of time and what
i've ended up doing in those cases i
have to say i haven't done one of those
for a while but but um
uh you know i end up writing out every
single word i'm gonna say
and what i found is i guess that i've
learned to write
more or less as i talk and so it's
uh you know when i'm ending up
essentially reading something
that i wrote word for word it's okay it
works
it's it doesn't sound like oh you're
just reading from a script and it's
really boring
um because i managed to write it as i
would say it anyway
and um and then uh uh you know
it's it's still seems perfectly possible
to to present it
as you would have been thinking it when
you wrote it
so anyway a few a few comments done but
but i think the thing for me that
has been um uh doing kind of live
live coding live programming to me
that's the most
engaged and energetic thing because it's
like you're figuring stuff out
in real time along with the audience if
you get feedback the feedback is always
great
then it's kind of like you can you can
adjust accordingly
and that to me generates uh kind of a
a good um uh good interaction with the
audience i mean the other thing that's
always an issue
is you know how do you start because
it's like even if you just know the
first three sentences you're going to
say
more or less that really helps a lot
often
you know if you're like here's this
audience
and um it's like i really didn't think
about anything i was going to say
once for me at least once i'm sort of
off and running and i've got
some kind of some kind of approach some
kind of uh
way that i'm dealing with this
particular audience it's um
then then one's often running and one's
in good shape but um
you know if one thinks so for example
for me you know i i'll
i'll give um talks that are to very
technical audiences
i'll give talks that are too uh uh more
to
what this is intended for kids and so on
um i you know
so i'm not sure the the you know if if
you're doing
i mean the other thing that happens is
so
okay the other question for people is
well what if
you just you know you're you're really
terrified of giving some talk in front
of a bunch of people
that's not really been my problem ever
in fact i
i i think one time years ago i
um uh when i first had these biometric
devices
that would measure heart rate and so on
i thought am i going to do this
i'm going to show off some some
biometric device and i'm going to
see whether when i'm in front of a big
audience whether my heart rate actually
goes up
and um well the answer was it didn't
so it was um uh you know for whatever
reason i i
but i think the point is that um
um somehow there comes a point where
you're just
like uh you know i i see people
who uh do great in one-on-one
interactions and then we put them in
front of an audience they kind of freeze
they're also people who do well in front
of an audience but one-on-one
they're very kind of uh they they don't
interact very well
i think that in terms of people where
where it's like oh my gosh i'm going to
be in front of this big audience and
and everybody's going to notice what i'm
doing it's like
um i don't know i i i think sometimes
people
uh kind of over over overthink
what's going to happen and they kind of
sometimes over prepare
and and that means that they end up
being sort of they over prepare the fact
that they're nervous about giving the
talk
and and the whole thing doesn't you know
it would it would do better
if they just were able to kind of uh
imagine they're talking to one person
you know pick a person
okay you're talking to that person the
fact there's a thousand other people
there
or 20 other people there or whatever
it's like who cares
you know you're mostly having this
conversation with this one person
um i think that's uh you know that's a
potential strategy i i don't know
um it's not that for me personally
that's not been
such an issue i mean the thing
that happens is that uh
you know sometimes i'm like
oh my gosh this is a talk that's going
to be an absolute disaster
because i haven't you know i haven't
really even thought about what i'm going
to say i don't really understand the
audience etcetera etcetera etcetera
and then when it gets started there's
enough kind of
energy and enough interaction with the
audience enough positive feedback or
something
goes really really well and sometimes
it'll be
like you're going to um um
uh you know you think that oh yeah this
is easy i understand it's audience
etcetera etcetera and it's like
you know nobody's responding you know
i'm sort of telling a joke and nobody's
responding to that and you know you get
and it gets to be very negative feedback
anyway a few two cents worth i mean to
tell a couple of little minus stories i
mean they
you know the other thing one one's doing
live coding kinds of presentations
to audiences obviously you have to have
a computer and a computer projector
and all that kind of thing it's got to
actually work um
and it's always bizarre to me that i've
given talks in just a huge
collection of different venues around
the world over the course of well
many decades now um but when i first
started using computers with computer
projectors and so on that was probably
in the 80s 1980s
and that was very early and when you
know complete
computer projections were these big
clunky things and they were really for
uh for protection televisions and
computers weren't portable
and et cetera et cetera et cetera and
things were much more difficult
and all kinds of crazy things happened
and uh
you know but the thing that was most
bizarre to me is in places where you
thought this couldn't possibly work
there's no way you know i remember being
in in moscow and russia
um sometime in what was that that must
have been
maybe 1991 and it's like we got this
projector
and its diagnostic messages are in
russian and
you know well there were
russian-speaking people there but it was
still it was a little bit and you know
things were connected there were
connectors that were different and all
this kind of thing and it's like
this isn't ever going to work and we had
to borrow some computer and
so on and so on and so on works fine
then you're in a situation where it's
like
you know this is the most you know
like like for example i gave a talk at
ted once which is some big fancy
conference
um and uh that has like the absolutely
top-of-the-line audio visual
setup and fortunately it was uh you know
i was like well let's just test this
you know you know a few hours before
and it's like oh my gosh this doesn't
work
and you know they have the the most
high-end thing where they've got a whole
bank of equipment and you know people
and and uh you know giant incredibly
high resolution
uh projectors and so on and oh my gosh
it doesn't work
well i learned something there which was
a very bizarre fact which is the way
that a
computer sends its data
to a projector or to an external display
it has to kind of negotiate the computer
may have a certain resolution to its
display
for example a computer might have 2000
pixels across the screen
and the projector might be projecting
might
only allow 1500 pixels across its
uh when it projects it so the question
is can the projector sort of tell the
computer
please only send me 1500 pixels across
because
if you have you know 2000 pixels across
the computer screen if you just say
well send me the first 1500 pixels well
then you don't see the whole whole
display if you say send me the whole
thing well it's a little bit tricky
because
you've got to take what was let's say
four pixels on the computer screen and
turn that into three pixels for the
projector you've got to figure out
if it was you know red red green blue
with the pixels
on the computer screen how does that
translate to the pixels on the projector
and so on so it's a bit tricky
and there's a whole elaborate kind of uh
you know
underworld or something of how computers
and projectors and so on communicate
uh something called eti which is some
mechanism for you no ea
am i remembering that correctly i'm not
sure i'm remembering that correctly
there's a there's an acronym i think i
got the right one but i might not have
done
um for how the um uh
how the computer sends back information
and in this particular case
the the uh the fancy audio visual system
was sending back
kind of fake information to the computer
that was totally confusing the computer
causing it to send completely the wrong
data the whole fancy audio visual system
uh was not working as a result and it
required having a little little weird
little box that was connected between
the computer
and the other stuff that was kind of
re-faking the signal that had to be sent
but so that's that's one of the weird
things that happens doing these things
in person
all right um
well let's see there's a completely
different question here
from pax why are there so many concepts
in mathematics that are not realized in
the physical world
actually one of the big surprises is
that a lot of the mathematics that has
been invented
has actually ended up being sometimes
invented but then
50 years 100 years later it ends up
being used to describe physics
so just just to review a little bit of
the history of mathematics and physics
and so on
i mean in the the the the kind of
mathematics
kind of originated mathematics as we
know it sort of originated in babylonian
times maybe 3000 years ago
and really there were two branches of
mathematics arithmetic
and geometry arithmetic was mostly used
for dealing with things to do with money
and amounts of money and so on
geometry used for surveying land and
deciding you know what was the area of
your
of you know of the land that you owned
and things like this
well at the time it wasn't obvious
whether
whether kind of these mathematical ideas
applied
to physics so to speak physics in those
days the most
sort of important physics was uh
looking at planets and so on and looking
at uh things in the sky
and it probably didn't didn't hurt that
you know there wasn't electric light
obviously in those days
and so you know the sky at night um
was probably you know it was very was
nice and nice and bright
and um people really noticed oh there's
this extra star-like thing that's moving
across the sky
oh it's it's a moving star well okay
then
you know we know now that's a planet and
um in the
in those days you know people had names
for these things they didn't really
quite know
all the details of what they were and
that they were things like the earth and
so on
um and they they but they tried to make
kind of models for where would mars be
where would jupiter be they knew about
mars jupiter saturn
that was as far as they knew they knew
about venus and mercury also
um but uh where would those i think they
knew about mercury yes they would have
known
mercury um the uh uh you know where will
those things be
like you know a week from now a month
from now
a year from now where will jupiter be in
the sky
and in fact one of the things that the
babylonians did is they kept very good
records so they had astronomical diaries
that they wrote every single day for 700
years
and in fact those diaries are give us
some of the best information we have
on things like when eclipses happened
and things which allow us to even today
uh understand things about the motion of
the earth and so on
that we can't get from making
measurements over shorter periods of
time
but in any case they they wanted to
figure out okay where's jupiter going to
be
you know some number of years from now
and by the way i mean a lot of things
that they discovered were things like
you know 19-year cycles like the uh
cycle for um uh uh tides and eclipses
and so on
that's that's 19 and something years
long it's it's rather impressive
that uh any civilization
group whatever kind of been kept keeping
records as consistently as that they
could really find
a 19-year cycle in something um it's
sort of a remarkable thing that you know
every day for 700 years and we we have
about one or two percent of that
um of that 700-year run still exists on
on tablets and so on and museums around
the world
um and sort of gradually been pieced
together but in any case the
the um so they were interested in
where's jupiter going to be and so they
tried to work out
uh they tried to use math to figure that
out and they said well
you know there's this curve and it goes
up and it goes up and it goes up they
didn't they they actually had a little
bit of ability to sort of
in a sense plot things like we do with
you know with plotting curves and so on
and they were like okay this curve is
going like that it's going to go to this
place at this time
and that was the beginning of sort of
the effort to
you know use math for for physics for
science
um was at that time and they did rather
well and then
later on there were sort of more
elaborate models that got developed
which again used
used math in those days for example
there were there were problems like
that there wasn't really a mathematical
notation that existed
people had to uh you know describe their
math in words you know there is the
circle and
next to the circle there's this other
one et cetera et cetera et cetera and
there's this thing
that that uh you know increases in
proportion to this and that
that and the other was all just words
the idea of notation for math didn't
didn't really come in until much much
later more like the 1400s and so on
um so that was kind of an impediment
actually in some of the early work
that was done even uh people like kepler
in the early 1600s was still doing
things like using music
notation you know music because music
notation of
where notes get placed on a stave and so
on that was introduced around 1000 ad
and um the so you know that was actually
used as sort of notation by kepler
because he didn't really have
math notation for certain kinds of
things but um
you know by the time that the big sort
of explosion of you can use math to do
science
was in the late 1600s with people well
first galileo and then newton
um basically realizing that there were
sort of mathematical calculations that
would allow you to explain things about
physics
and in particular newton ended up
inventing calculus as a way to explain
the motion
of not just planets but also comets
which have these um
uh uh elliptical trajectories and so on
and um
um uh that was that was kind of the um
the big thing and so the methods of
mathematics that were in that case
calculus was sort of invented in the
service of physics
what had existed at the time was
geometry a lot of geometry
a lot of things about properties of
ellipses properties of this properties
of that
if you look at the early works on
astronomy by people like ptolemy
reggio montanas people like that you'll
find that they're full of theorems that
say things like
there can only be at most i forget how
many it is
uh three eclipses in a given year and
their proof of that theorem
is a bunch of pictures of triangles
showing that oh because the sun the moon
the earth
are arranged in this way you can only
arrange them that way and it's it's a
geometrical proof
so i suppose the first place where where
things were invented that we used later
was was
back when euclid maybe first century bc
or so
was doing um
was codifying geometry and putting
together his collection of
axioms and theorems about geometry
most of the geometry that people learn
in like high school and so on
was known by euclid and was written down
by euclid
um and uh you know things like i don't
know you draw
in a circle you draw you know you you
have something on the diameter
of the circle and you put lines up to
meet on the circle
oh that angle is always 90 degrees that
was that was one of the fairly
elementary results
of euclid but so those results sort of
one of the first places where sort of
math was invented
math was not really used for a long time
and then math turned out to be useful
was in the use of geometry for
for doing astronomical calculations and
astronomical sort of
theorem proving another place where
geometry showed up was an optics um
figuring out if you have light rays and
you have a lens for example and the
the light rays are going along and the
lens makes the light rays converge it
bends the light rays
and there's but through a certain angle
and there are all sorts of properties of
you know this angle is equal to that
angle and so on and so on and so on
and it becomes kind of like a standard
high school geometry problem
to figure out what's going to happen so
that was a that was another
another use but then what happened is
through the 1600s 1700s even 1800s
uh most of the math that was done was
done in the service of physics
so people invented uh these things
called differential equations
which were kind of equations that say if
you change this
if this changes that's how it changes
the rate at which something else changes
or if this changes at a certain rate the
rate at which something else changes
is determined by that it's an equation
that says as you change the
the size of this or the rate of that
then it changes the rate of this other
thing in that way
so so that was kind of the the
mathematical approach that was developed
particularly in 1700s early 1800s
that was kind of the big thing that was
being developed in math
um and that was the thing that was
developed for doing physics and first it
was
for things like fluid mechanics the
motion of water and
air and so on then for things like
electrodynamics
electric magnetic fields things like
that they all sort of fitted into that
kind of mathematical framework
the thing that happened in math in the
1800s was
people started doing math that didn't
immediately connect to the physical
world and so
one of the first things there was one of
one of the big results of euclid
or big claims of euclid is parallel
lines
never crossed and so
if you just draw parallel lines on a
plane it's they don't cross
if you draw parallel lines even on a
sphere
they can cross and one of the things
that was sort of believed is that
in in actual space as it exists in the
universe
in physics parallel lines never cross
well it turns out that isn't true
but the idea that you even should
consider a mathematical setup
where parallel lines could cross you
have a space where parallel lines can
cross
that was an idea a chap called labysky
in the 1830s
40s and so on was was really big on
that idea was an idea that was sort of
imagined in math
but didn't really have a place in
physics until einstein came along and
figured out
our still well somewhat current theory
of gravity
around 1915 um where
that has the idea that space is actually
curved that the presence of mass
uh is produces curvature in space which
is what leads to gravity
and it leads parallel lines as in you
shoot
two laser beams and they go in quotes
lines
except you might think they were
parallel but actually the effect of
gravity
is to curve space and cause those
parallel lines potentially to cross
so so that was another place where sort
of the ideas of laboratory about curved
space
ended up oh about 80 years later
becoming relevant to physics
then there was an idea of chap called
every scalwar came up with this idea of
group theory
which has to do with sort of abstractly
figuring out if you have let's say an
object i don't know a tetrahedron or
something
and you say what are the possible things
you can do to the tetrahedron or take a
rubik's cube for example
what are the possible motions of a
rubik's cube and
if you if you you know twist one side
four times you'll get back to where you
started from
if you twist several different things in
different ways it will take you a lot
longer to get back
to what you started from and there's a
kind of way of of writing down sort of
an algebra
of if you have this particular move that
you make on the rubik's cube and you
combine it with this movie combine it
with that move
how is that equivalent to some other set
of moves you could do or how does that
set of moves eventually
come back to the rubik's cube all being
put back together again and so on
um and that idea of sort of thinking
about the sort of abstract
notion of this sort of algebra of things
you can do
that idea of group theory that
originated in the 1830s or so
um and again it was something which at
the beginning was a purely mathematical
interest it was invented
for understanding things about equations
of the fifth degree
equations that involve you know
quadratic equations like x squared and
so on
x to the fifth and so on uh there was
a whole question about whether you could
uh solve those equations in
in terms of of of cube roots and square
roots and so on
and this was a proof that you couldn't
and that came from the sort of abstract
area of group theory
so for a long time it's like group
theory is nice and group theory is in
math
but group theory isn't relevant to
physics by the time
uh by particularly the 1950s and 1960s
but even there have been other
work earlier than that turns out group
theory is super relevant
to understand uh things about uh well
first
atoms and then things about particles
and quarks
and so on and actually group theory is a
big part of the story
of how kind of the modern conception of
physics is put together
so again a span of something like 100 or
so years
between when it was sort of invented as
a math idea and when it ended up
getting applied in physics now there are
other kinds of things that got invented
by the late 1800s people were very big
on this idea of let's just
imagine a kind of a formal system
something that you could just sort of
write down and do manipulations and
calculations with
even though it has nothing to do with
anything we know about in the real world
and so for example one thing that was
invented at that time by a
chap called cantor was transfinite
numbers which are numbers which are kind
of like
they're different shades of infinity you
might say oh we've got an infinite
number
it's just infinity there's just you know
a thing called infinity
well he had this idea of transfinite
numbers where there's just
an infinite number of different
variations of infinity you can have sort
of infinity infinity plus one
infinity to the power infinity and so on
and there's a way of distinguishing
these things
and so there's this whole sort of uh
world of transfinite numbers
so that's an example of something that
was invented in the um
uh in the 1880s or so
and uh still today doesn't really have
a physics application actually in our
physics project
i think there is some slight sign that
we will need to use transfer ideas from
transfinite numbers
um but mostly that's an example of a
piece of math that sort of got
in a sense over built and wasn't
relevant to physics
um in other places
there's uh it's sort of interesting
because my basic
point of view is whenever you have sort
of an elegant enough way of thinking
about things
there will be a way to apply it but
somehow
part of that is what you choose to study
as much as
how you choose to study it so for
example there are plenty of phenomena in
physics
we just say that's really complicated we
don't know how that works
even though we might know how to sort of
break it down into small pieces and know
how the small pieces work we don't know
how to build it up again that's true in
for example
fluid turbulence when you see sort of
water flowing quickly
in a waterfall or something like that
you see all of this
you know bubbling around water and so on
it's very complicated we still don't
really know how that works
um even though we know perfectly well
how the underlying physics
of water works and so in in um
in cases like that there's sort of a
question of well what do you choose to
study
there are questions about the waterfall
that we can study
using certain kinds of mathematical
methods and then we can say great that
you know those mathematical methods
worked but there are other kinds of
things that we don't manage to study
and and and there we we can't really um
uh
you know we there's a sort of question
once we've invented a mathematical
method
usually we can find a thing to study for
which that mathematical method works
so long as the mathematical method is
somehow elegant enough
and i've certainly noticed that i you
know made up a bunch of models of
sort of computational models of things
and when the models are very clean and
very simple
they always get applications when the
models are these very complicated things
that
are very specially constructed well then
maybe maybe they're of interest
for studying the model itself but
they're not of interest for studying so
the physical world
so i think that's some uh
it's kind of the um uh and i mean when
you say that many concepts in
mathematics not realized in physics i
i think that the vast majority have in
fact
ended up getting realized in physics
partly because of the choice of what we
study in physics
um and you know i think in in our in our
physics project recently
a whole kind of boat load of new sort of
advanced
mathematical ideas that have been
floating around for 100 years or more
that um uh particularly ideas about um
and from mathematical logic that have
seemed like they're just like oh well
that's interesting
for studying mathematical logic and the
foundations of mathematics but wait why
would we care about that in physics
now it's incredibly relevant there are
notions i think of the church rossa
property which is a
kind of an obscure property in
mathematical logic is the reason
that relativity works in the physical
world um
in our models so these things which were
kind of obscure pieces of mathematical
logic
end up becoming applied to physics and
that's it's an interesting phenomenon um
anyway there's probably probably more to
say about that i think we've got a lot
of other questions here so let me
let me try and get to a few of these
others
oh boy there's a question here what
cryptocurrencies am i a fan of do you
think any of them were winning big in
2021
uh that's that's more of a um i think
the
uh maybe i should explain for people's
benefit what cryptocurrencies
are so the most famous cryptocurrency is
bitcoin
um that's been the most valuable
cryptocurrency i think it's like
these days what was it it's like half a
trillion dollars
is the value of all of the bitcoin that
exists today
and uh that that's a big number because
that's you know that's comparable to
that's at least half the size of uh
the very biggest companies and and their
their values and so on
so okay a little bit of an explanation
what is bitcoin what are
cryptocurrencies what's the idea
so i guess that the big thing to start
from is
is the idea of blockchain which is kind
of the underlying technology of
cryptocurrencies
and and here's here's the basic basic
point
so there's a question of if you do
financial transactions if you
say so-and-so is going to own this piece
of land etc etc etc
you want to make a ledger of what
happened you want to somehow have a
record
of oh this person owns this piece of
land this person
owns this number of dollars this person
paid this number of dollars to this
person and so on
you want to have some kind of you know
ledger of what happened
so that you can say this is really how
things are in the world
you know so and so paid so and so a
thousand dollars
and now the the the new person has that
thousand dollars and the old person
doesn't have that thousand dollars
and you want there to be no doubt about
that you want it to be the case that
there's a
sort of a a uh information about that so
in in the world in general you know when
you have a bank account or something
i mean there was a time a hundred years
150 years ago or something
when if you deposited money in the bank
there was a vault
underneath the bank and your money got
put in that vault
at least in a first approximation then
things got much more complicated and
banks started lending out money to other
people and
and their whole whole elaborate system
of modern banking
got started but in some first
approximation you could imagine you know
you put your money in a bank
the thing is just sitting there in you
know in a vault
underneath the bank but in modern times
that's absolutely not how it works
and instead it's just an electronic
record that
yes you owe own this this money
and when you pay the money to somebody
else then they get it and you
you get you don't have it anymore so
the idea of blockchain is
the question is who maintains that
ledger so for example
typically if you buy a piece of real
estate you say i'm buying this house
the question is how does anybody know
that you own that house
well the answer is there's a registry
a central registry a registry of deeds a
title registry
and somewhere you can go to your local
town whatever
and there will be a piece of paper that
says you own this
this piece of land and that piece of
paper is kind of
securely kept by your town or whatever
else
and and if somebody says no no i own it
you go to the title registry and you can
say no no it's not true here's the piece
of paper that proves i own it
okay so so the the the issue is how do
you get
what's a kind of a a way to do that so
one way to do it is you just have one
centralized place now let's imagine you
had two title registries
there'd be a problem or three title
registries and each one
has pieces of paper that says this
person owns this piece of land this
person owns this piece of lab well what
happens if the
if the pieces of paper and the different
title registries disagree
if two titles registry say you know
jane owns this piece of land and uh
one title registry says amy owns this
piece of land
what happens then well so that's why
in in most traditional sort of ledgers
there's only one copy because there's
one definitive version of
uh you know who owns the thing so what
happens with blockchain that the sort of
the big idea of blockchain is to have a
distributed ledger
to have it be the case that you can have
thousands of copies of the ledger
and that are distributed on different
computers around the world
but that all have the property that they
all
somehow are made to agree okay so it's a
pretty clever system
that's kind of elaborate that basically
is a system of incentives
that causes people to want those ledgers
to all agree
and and the idea in in in
in bitcoin for example is here's the
idea the
the idea is that what's going to happen
is on this blockchain
there are these blocks and a block
contains let's say a thousand
transactions
doesn't matter what the number is let's
let's say a hundred thousand doesn't
matter how many transactions
and that what's going to happen is at
some point
that block is going to be on the
blockchain it's going to be part of the
ledger
and everybody's going to agree that that
block is correct
and so every so often you want to put a
block
on the blockchain that contains some
bucket of transactions and everybody's
going to confirm
that yes that block is correct and so
it's going to become part of the ledger
shared across you know 5 000 machines 10
000 machines
whatever it is around the world that are
running uh
bitcoin blockchain servers and so on so
so the question then is
how do you get everybody to the point
where they agree
that what's in that block is correct so
first question is
if you're doing a transaction if you
want to so
what's in the block what's in the block
is a bunch of records that say
a paid b some number of bitcoins
and or or some number of satoshi which
is uh 100 millionth of a bitcoin
um the uh you know so so
some some um uh somebody paid
something and you're recording uh and
you want to record that's in this ledger
and and then if you want to know well
how much bitcoin do you have
you just go back in this ledger and you
can say well i started with this amount
and then i you know i paid this person
this this person paid me this this etc
etc
cetera you can figure out how much do
you now have and because this ledger
is something that everybody has agreed
to everybody will agree about how much
bitcoin i have
okay so the question then is how does so
i i want to make a transaction and what
i would do then is i'd say okay i'm
going to make this transaction
i have to prove that i'm i'm allowed to
make this transaction
and then i have to sort of submit this
transaction and people have to decide
whether
whether they should add it to these
blocks that are being added to the the
blockchain ledger
um this is a little complicated i i i
can probably explain how this works
um the um okay
so the question is um
well let me say roughly how it works and
then maybe go through more details
there's this very a bizarre idea of
so-called mining of bitcoin
and actually i i happen to think that
this idea actually came from
some science that i did in the early
1980s and i think the person who
invented bitcoin
and that sort of an anonymous thing
nobody really officially knows who that
was
um but i have pretty sure that um
a bunch of things that i figured out
about science to do with this phenomenon
of computational irreducibility
turned into this incredibly bizarre
thing that i'm about to describe it's
called proof-of-work
for bitcoin and so the question is
who gets to say that they made up the
contents for a block
in the in the bitcoin blockchain you
know of
of the maybe 5 000 uh people
who are running bitcoin servers around
the world who are going to get copies of
the of the
of the bitcoin blockchain who gets to be
the one who says
i made up this block well that's
determined
by who has again i'm skipping a bunch of
stuff because
there's a there's a whole depth of
description here about how
the cryptography works in in um uh
in these things but but roughly it's
some uh
what has to happen is if you solve this
particular computational problem
it's kind of a pointless silly
computational problem
that says basically a thing that usually
is used for
taking uh for example a message and
generating a so-called hash code
you're generating you're saying given
this message i'm going to figure out
what's a ten digit number
that is a a good sort of short
description of this message
and if i change the message i want to
change that 10-digit number most of the
time although
there'll be some messages that lead up
ended up with the same 10-digit number
just because there isn't as much
information
in a 10-digit number as there is in your
whole message well
so the idea is can you find a message
which will produce a particular hash
code or a hash code which ends in some
number of zeros
um and that's a bizarre kind of
pointless problem
but it's also a problem that that is it
seems to be a sort of computationally
irreducible problem it seems to be
something where you have to do a certain
amount of computational work
um in order to answer that question and
so the idea is
that you can have different computers
around the world different people around
the world who are all sort of competing
to find that uh to sort of solve that
computational problem
and be the one who says yes i'm the one
who figured this out first
i'm going to get to put the next block
on the bitcoin blockchain
and it's kind of a weird thing because
that process of trying to solve that
computational problem
just takes a lot of computational effort
and so people build all kinds of special
purpose computers that are specially set
up
to be really fast at doing you know giga
hashes
per second a billion hashes per second
to try and find the um
find these answers and uh you know
people
spend lots of electrical power running
those computers and it's all a kind of
very weird setup
that um and i certainly i couldn't have
imagined when i came up with this idea
of computational irreducibility
that it would be used in for this very
bizarre purpose
but it's kind of like when you think
about uh
money that where where gold is sort of
the thing that's backing the money
it's like one of the things that depends
on is gold is hard to mine
um it's you know it's hard to find the
gold it's hard to get it out of the
ground and so on
it's um and that's why you can sort of
justify
saying gold is valuable it's the same
kind of thing with bitcoin mining but
anyway so so then
you're you're kind of um uh you're
you're taking um uh so essentially there
are uh the bitcoin miners can
say yes i got this i got this thing
first so i'm the one who gets to add
this block
and one of the things that happens is
everybody who wants their transaction
included in that block including that
piece of the ledger they pay a small
commission
they pay some number of cents or or or
10 cents whatever it is one cent
um they they pay that to be able to uh
to to get their their transaction
included in the bitcoin
blockchain ledger okay so then the
person who
minds who gets to be the person who
creates that block
picks up all those commissions they they
get to take
all those commissions that people are
paying they get those commissions
so it's worth doing this kind of mining
of bitcoin
to to get those commissions and so on
now i'm simplifying a bit how this works
but
but basically what's happening is uh
somebody says yes
i've got this block and other people
will then confirm that block and
gradually people will have gotten to the
point where they say yes
it's going to get copied onto all those
4 000 machines and there's usually on
bitcoin there's a block mined about
every 10 minutes
um and usually it takes about 24 hours
before people are like
absolutely absolutely certain that this
block is not going to get reversed
nobody's going to say oh there's
there's more people who say this is the
correct block then that's the correct
block
but okay so what is the how does this
what's the point of all of this and how
does it all work it's really a very
weird thing because
in a sense bitcoin is valuable because
people think it's valuable
people have put money into it half a
trillion dollars into it
and they think well actually they
haven't put all that money
in but that's what they think it's worth
so if you say
i'm going to convert my bitcoin to
dollars then i'm going to get a
conversion that's based on the fact that
all the bitcoin in the world
is worth half a trillion dollars um and
and the question is why
is that the right number well nobody
really knows it's like people if people
are prepared to pay it then it's the
right number um
it's it's a it's very sort of flexible
thing and and that means as
as people believe different things about
bitcoin and so on
it'll be oh it's more valuable today
because more people are trying to buy it
oh it's less valuable nobody cares about
it it's gone down in value
or you know some government outlawed it
oh it's going to go down in value
because people not as many people can
hold it
or whatever else or people are worried
about how you know existing currencies
are unstable
so it's going to go up it's much more
volatile it it
it jumps around in value much more than
than
most currencies of most countries jump
around in value
but any case so so the thing that
bitcoin mostly
is is a sort of repository of value
people
put people put money into bitcoin
why well because they hope that when
it's in bitcoin it's going to go up in
value
and they're going to be able to sell it
again and get more money back they're
kind of speculating on what's going to
happen
in the value of bitcoin and that is the
vast majority of what has been spent
on on you know what what is in bitcoins
people speculating on what's going to
happen with bitcoin
now you might say well can you actually
use it to buy things
well you know at various times people
have like i remember there's
one place in palo alto california
where you know it's like a like a coffee
shop type thing where you can
you can buy your coffee for bitcoin i'm
not sure that that's a very
very i've i've seen that only in one
place um
there are sometimes there's uh there are
uh bitcoin exchange machines where you
can put cash
in and get bitcoin sent to your account
um and those have existed those have
sort of popped up in you know doughnut
stores and things like that in different
places
i don't know whether those are still
still going and unfortunately they often
have these big signs on them saying
be careful make sure that what you're
doing with bitcoin isn't a scam
because it's very it's it's something
where people think
bitcoin is very untrackable kind of
thing now it's a little weird that they
think it's untrackable
because in some sense bitcoin is the
most trackable of anything
because the ledger of all the
transactions that happened is absolutely
publicly available
the only thing that isn't publicly
available is who is behind those
transactions
everybody gets kind of an id and you get
these kind of
these kind of weird long numbers that
represent your account
represent who you are and so on and uh
you know
what there isn't a connection between
the who you are
and who you actually are in real life
and that number that's that's put that's
associated with bitcoin
but it's it's one of these things where
where in a sense it's a more open
uh you know ledger of what's going on
than than
than anything else it's just that that
final last step of who's the actual
person behind this
is is not is not immediately known but
any case so people
people say oh this is an untrackable way
of transferring money from this to that
and
to some extent that's true and and
governments get very concerned about oh
what if
everybody moved their money into bitcoin
and then and then avoided paying taxes
or moved their money to another country
moved their money out of our country so
so nobody's buying you know nobody has
venezuelan currency anymore
because it all turned into bitcoin or
something um and at times various
governments
have considered uh uh making some kind
of digital currency
be there be making some kind of thing
like bitcoin be the currency for their
country or even making bitcoin
be the currency for their country that
hasn't happened yet at least
um and there are a bunch of reasons why
that probably isn't a very good idea
um but any case so the you know the the
the main
thing that's going on with bitcoin is
people speculating on whether the value
of bitcoin is going to go up
um and um the actual
buying of things with bitcoin not very
much of that another bizarre
thing is so-called icos initial coin
offerings
where people are are inventing new
cryptocurrencies
and are selling people uh initial kind
of shares in that new cryptocurrency
in another existing cryptocurrency like
bitcoin so a bunch of the
the kind of uh the the the the sort of
transactions that happen on bitcoin
are for icos for people buying other new
cryptocurrencies so
bitcoin is mostly so there are these
different cryptocurrencies
bitcoin is the biggest the second
biggest is one called ethereum
and then there are a whole sequence of
other ones um the uh
uh the and we've worked with a lot of
these companies so i
i know lots about a bunch of these
cryptocurrencies um
the uh uh these i shouldn't say
companies because they're often very
weird organizations that are sort of
combination foundations non-profits
this that companies et cetera et cetera
they're sort of weird
weird kinds of constructions but um one
of the big ideas
uh that sort of originated with ethereum
is this idea of smart contracts
which is the idea that not only can you
have transactions
that where you have sort of this pa
person paid this person this amount in
this
in this cryptocurrency you can also have
sort of things that
have more logic to them that depend on
other things
and for example one thing you can do is
you can have
a a contract that says just
i own this thing and so on on ethereum
for a long time
the favorite thing to own was crypto
kitties which are
what are they they are completely
virtual
things and they're you know they're
these cool looking
pictures of cats and people can say i
own this cryptokitty
and you can prove you own it because
there's this smart contract on ethereum
that says that you own the crypto kitty
and it's on the ethereum blockchain
ledger
um and so it sort of proves you really
own this crypto kitty and then you can
say well i own this cryptocurrency but
i'm prepared to sell you this
cryptokitty and eventually you build up
a market in cryptokitties
and you can use that and then so you're
essentially building value
in cryptocurrencies even though what is
this cryptokitty
it is simply your right to have it is
simply the fact that you have this
weird-looking cat
that has these particular
characteristics now in the real world
there are plenty of markets where people
are buying things where
it's pretty virtualized like that i mean
it's also true in in computer games and
video games
that um people also have virtual goods
there which they're buying and selling
and to some extent that's merged with
the idea of buying and selling things on
in cryptocurrencies although not as much
as one might have expected
but in any case so so the question that
was asked is what's what are the
what are the new and exciting
cryptocurrencies that um uh and what
what will happen to cryptocurrencies and
i think that the what will happen to
cryptocurrencies is a complicated
question about the economics of the
world
that i don't think i have any any great
insight about and
you know what will happen to you know
these various stimuluses that um
governments are putting into their
economies to you know uh which
in some cases amounts to sort of
printing money to give everybody a check
for x number of dollars or something
um and uh you know how will that affect
the value of dollars altogether
how will that compare to uh people
deciding to put their money into bitcoin
instead of into dollars
these are complicated questions a bunch
of which have to do with the way that
this pandemic gets unwound and so on
and exactly what decisions be made by
central banks
and all those kinds of things um again
one could talk about this i'm not sure
it's
this is quite the right venue for that
um but um
what happens is uh there are always new
ideas for how to make cryptocurrencies
so for example
this idea of proof of work this crazy
computational interdisability idea
um there are other approaches proof of
stake is another idea
where you basically have a sort of
pseudo-democracy where people based on
how much of the cryptocurrency they own
they get to kind of vote on whether they
think that this block is correct
to to add to the blockchain things like
that so there are a bunch of ideas like
that there are
there are ideas where people have sort
of sort of variable possibilities for
how
the how the thing gets structured and
people can kind of like
change the constitution so to speak by
an appropriate
uh kind of vote of people who own that
cryptocurrency those kinds of things
there are lots of
different governance mechanisms and and
in general with cryptocurrency
one of the big sort of interesting
things is the is the way that you create
these incentives like
oh nobody wants to fake this because if
they fake it
then this will be bad and it has value
to do the correct thing
etc etc etc so so we've worked a bunch
on this and actually the thing that i
think is the most interesting ultimately
a couple of things with with
cryptocurrencies so so one thing is
uh usually with with real money it has
value
because it is a a medium
that's dealing with actual economic
activity actually people making things
and selling things to people
and doing services and charging people
for those services and so on
that's what real that's what economies
are really based on
and the currency the dollars that get
exchanged
are really just a reflection of people
sort of uh using some medium
to to pay each other for those kinds of
real economic things that are happening
so there aren't really real economic
things that are happening mostly in
cryptocurrencies and that's a problem
because it means there isn't the same
stability there isn't that same level of
real things
that are that are backing the sort of
the value of the cryptocurrency
but something which i think is a coming
sort of thing
is what i like to call computational
contracts
when people write legal contracts they
say you know i'm going to do this
if this happens you'll pay me this if
that happens this will happen etcetera
etcetera etcetera
those contracts today are pretty much
written down
in english words or in words of some
language
they'll they'll say you know whereas the
party of the first part does this and
blah blah blah blah
in legalese but it's basically something
that just sort of says in words what's
going to happen
so the question is can you make that
into something which says instead of in
words
in code in some kind of computational
language what's going to happen
well for that you have to have that
computational language be enough
connected to the real world that it
knows whether the thing happened or not
that it knows you know it's connected to
some camera it's connected to something
some bank balance somewhere it's
connected to some other thing in the
world
where it can say those were the
provisions of the contract did you
actually do them
oh it can know whether you did them and
then the actual
sort of content of the contract can be
represented in this computational
language
and then you can kind of it can decide a
computer can decide
was this contract followed and oh yes
you know so-and-so gets to pay so and so
such and such an amount of money
or not as the case may be so this idea
of computational contracts it's sort of
they've
they've happened in a few areas they're
gradually expanding
our kind of wolfram language
computational language
is i think the the most suitable for
actually creating broad computational
contracts
and so it's part of the reason we've
been sort of involved in the in the
world of blockchain
is because computational contracts are
something
which when they are widely used will be
a thing where computers interact with
computers
and a lot of sort of contractual
activity is happening autonomously
so right now contracts are like a human
says you're supposed to do this
somebody says oh yeah okay i'm supposed
to do that and if everything blows up
you take it to court and some judge
decides or some jury decides
did you do what you were supposed to do
but in the future
one can expect that those are
computational contracts and they're
purely decided
by what the computational language says
should happen and they can be decided by
computer
and that means you can have these giant
chains of contracts where
if something happens that causes the
triggering of a whole chain of contracts
all autonomously all just happening
without human intervention
things could go horribly wrong in that
setup but but um uh
in um uh you know if you if you get it
right
then it's a very efficient way to
operate many kinds of things
so in that situation some number of
contracts of that kind
will probably want to use cryptocurrency
as
the medium that they're exchanging
because it's convenient to do that
if the contract is for a small enough
amount of money probably nobody cares
about having sort of the
the transparency of cryptocurrency it's
a really huge amount of money
probably people want the security of
being able to say something goes
horribly wrong
i can take it to court and there will be
some chain of humans who decide what to
do but there's an intermediate range
where probably cryptocurrency is pretty
good
but computational contracts don't exist
yet in well they exist
but they're not very widely used i mean
there'll be a time when trillions of
dollars of value
is exchanged all the time in
computational contracts and when that
happens
there will be sort of real economic
activity on top of which you can build
the value of a cryptocurrency
but so so that hasn't quite happened yet
and i don't think that will happen the
next year it will gradually happen
over the course of quite a few years uh
the other thing in the world of
cryptocurrencies
actually uh we recently had an idea
that uh sort of comes out of the physics
project and and here's one of the big
problems of cryptocurrencies
you know with bitcoin i mentioned you
you're putting in these blocks which are
on the blockchain which are
you know this ledger of all the
transactions but the time between each
block is about 10 minutes
and the time before you absolutely know
that this was a really secure
transaction
might be as long as today and um so
that's very very slow
so if you want to be exchanging money
with people and so on you want to do it
reasonably fast
it's some that's it's too slow
and also the amount that you have to pay
to sort of
justify having the i don't know what it
is 5 000 people
who have a copy of the bitcoin
blockchain on their computers
uh to justify sort of having that be be
kept on all those computers
it's a fair amount of money so it's
expensive to do transactions and it's
slow to do transactions
and so there's a question is there a
much better way to do it and what we
realized through our physics project
is that there is actually a much better
way it looks like there's a much better
way
that very amusingly uses a bunch of
ideas from quantum mechanics and so on
that uh the way that that works in our
physics project
to be able to make a much faster version
of something like a cryptocurrency
except it'll have weird features like
for example
it'll be the case that if you don't care
if you allow your bank balance to vary
by
let's say one percent you can find out
what
the value should be very very quickly
but if you insist on it being absolutely
precise you might have to wait longer
and it's kind of like the uncertainty
principle in quantum mechanics and it
actually happens for exactly the same
reason
in the system that we're imagining and
um so one thing to me that's interesting
about this potential
sort of crypto crypto well blockchain um
is more general than cryptocurrency um
is that
it's actually very much based on the
ideas of quantum mechanics which is this
thing that people don't have good
intuition about
and i think one of the things for me
that's kind of at least amusing
is that uh if if in fact it becomes the
case that people often do transactions
using this kind of blockchain then
people will start to have an intuition
about
quantum-like phenomena because they will
be experiencing it every day
in the way that those transactions
happen so that's one of the another sort
of coming attraction
um but uh uh no i don't know um i
i can't uh tell you a prediction for
whether you know
cardano or tezos or or um
uh ripple or this or that or the other
is going to um
uh uh you know go up or down in the in
the near future
um oh my gosh so many questions
um
there's the question here about uh about
bitcoin and and
and cryptocurrencies are big banks and
governments trying to undermine the
legitimacy of cryptocurrencies
you know i don't think that
cryptocurrencies
are particularly favored
by but governments because in a sense a
cryptocurrency
is just this thing sort of operated by
this mysterious network of computers
supposedly without human intervention
and kind of governments are in the
business
of running how the world works and you
know we've discovered in this pandemic
for example
even if you thought governments didn't
matter turns out when you have a big
public health disaster like this
you have governments do matter somebody
has to centrally
say oh you've got to do this or that or
the other
um and that's you know government it
matters where the government makes the
right decision the wrong decision et
cetera et cetera et cetera
that that kind of centralization to a
government doesn't seem to matter i mean
we've
you know people have often gotten to the
point of view uh
i have to say i sometimes think this
that the less government the better so
to speak
and the less one has to sort of
interfere with things the better
but it's kind of like somebody has to
decide you drive on the right or left
hand side of the road
that has to be a centrally made decision
well another
kind of decision that seems to be
necessary to make centrally
is things about the amount of money the
number of dollars you print
the money supply the the the rate at
which the government will lend out money
to people t-bills things like this
those are the things which sort of have
to be centrally decided by the
government
and governments feel that by making
those sensitive decisions they get
to you know control what's happening
some people may say they're controlling
it for good some people may say they're
controlling it
for bad it does you know that's that's a
thing but but um
the government at least thinks they have
levers that they can pull that will make
things happen
like if it turned out that you know the
economy in some country was just
grinding to a halt or the currency was
you know dramatically inflating
over time the governments think that
they have levers they can pull
that will sort of control what's
happening so if it starts to be the case
that a lot of
value a lot of the economic value of the
countries and cryptocurrencies
that gets very scary for governments
because those levers just don't work
they're not attached to anything
now it's also the case in many countries
where there is the so-called informal
economy
in other words where people are just
paying each other uh either
in currency or by barter and they're not
reporting that to the government
and they're usually not reporting it
because they don't want to pay the tax
which the government will levy on those
transactions
um and and so sometimes it's hard for a
government to know you know
it's hard to control that because it's
like well you know you can
you can try and enforce nobody can do
those transactions
but that's about all you can do you
don't know what's happening you can't
pull the standard levers to change the
way the economy works
if most of the economy is operating in a
way that doesn't depend on the
government
so i think governments generally
are not you know it's like for in many
cases it's like it'd be better if
cryptocurrencies just went away
and and it's very complicated to know
for example how tax should work on
cryptocurrencies
i mean that's that's some uh and um i
think that um
um and so also people worry about um
uh you know i was very amused a year or
two ago now
um you know people worry a lot about
scams with cryptocurrencies it's a
it's you know very easy for somebody to
put up a website and say i'm creating a
cryptocurrency
invested in my cryptocurrency i'm going
to do amazing things it's just complete
nonsense
right and it's kind of amusing because
uh i guess it was the fcc
securities and exchange commission in
the us put up a website
for a fake cryptocurrency and basically
you clicked on this thing
and it was it was really funny actually
um it had you know
it had pictures of people sort of
reclining in the sun on a beach
somewhere
of you know be that you know you get to
be this
if you invest in that cryptocurrency and
so on it was it was quite over the top
actually it's quite quite amusing
but it was a fake and you know if you
clicked on any of the buttons it would
say basically
you know this is a you know you could
have been had if this was a
if this wasn't a government site this
could have been a scam and somebody
could have been taking your money
and doing nothing useful with it and
just you know spending it on themselves
and
and not giving you anything of value
back so so the fact that it got to the
point where the us government was
running
kind of a a fake scam site
um meant that uh i thought that was a
strange moment actually for for um
uh for the web and and for the way that
things work and for the
for the sort of you know don't trust
everything you see on the web even the
government is running
you know fake sites so to speak so
in any case it um uh
it was the concern it is a concern that
people will just get you know that it's
in sort of
an area where where there's a lot of
kind of people couldn't say i put up a
website i'm going to take in your money
it's all nonsense and then people will
get upset
but that's a kind of a separate thing
from a government getting upset
because it's like we've lost control you
know everybody in our country
is is all their money is in bitcoin
and you know we can't control that so to
speak and sometimes countries get to the
point where they're very worried about
their currency leaving the country
because it becomes harder to sort of
keep value in the country
and then they try and put you know uh
exchange controls on their currency and
so on and that's
happened with but i don't keep track of
which exact countries have done that at
this moment in time
um but uh uh there are there are plenty
of countries in the world right now
where there are exchange controls
and if the money is in bitcoin it's like
sorry you don't get to do that because
bitcoin
is this global international thing
that's just based on a network of
computers
you don't get to tell people oh sorry
you can't take your money that was in
such and such a currency out of the
country
so so yes it's a it's a um i think it's
not
um uh you know it's kind of an
alternative it's a way of
of potentially making something that is
sort of transcends
the uh what governments provide
unfortunately it doesn't really work
because the truth is that um people
tried to actually make
a um a sort of a purely autonomous
system
where it would sort of develop value and
be something that was purely under sort
of computer control i'll tell you what
happened to it
it was interesting story it was a thing
called the the dow the distributed
autonomous organization
and it was a thing it was essentially an
investment vehicle
on ethereum and the idea was people
invest money in this thing and it gets
spent on useful projects
and you get paid back based on those
useful projects and it's all a good
thing
okay so fine idea
problem was that the website proudly
said there are no humans involved in
running this
this is just being run with computer
code and with essentially computational
contracts
okay well somebody found a bug in those
computational contracts
and that bug allowed them to transfer 50
million dollars to themselves
okay so they did and then they said so
the question is was that
actually against any rules and it's like
this whole thing said on its website
everything is run with code
it's just code the code defines the law
here
okay so this person said well the code
defines the law i found what
what many people would say was a bug
because it wasn't intended
that somebody just be able to transfer
50 million dollars to themselves
it was intended that this money would
get used
for venture capital for for projects and
so on but it didn't actually
you know it was it said all over the
place this is all governed by code
there's no by computer code there's
nothing uh there's nothing other than
that
so so it's even a question whether there
was sort of really anything wrong with
the person saying well i'm
i'm just following the code but i
transfer 50 million dollars to myself
and so people were like well that was
the wrong thing to do you know that was
very very shocking
but unfortunately there was no direct
recourse because there wasn't
wasn't like you could say you did the
wrong thing you broke this contract look
i can i can wave the piece of paper
i'll take you to court i'll you know
i'll get to i'll get a government
to enforce the fact that you got to
follow the law
because there wasn't any government
involved it was all just computer code
okay so you might wonder what actually
happened so the big question was
would the sort of majority of people um
decide that they would just uh
ignore the code that this person run
and change this ledger change the
blockchain and just go back and say
reverse out that transaction
we'll pretend that transaction didn't
happen even though they'd ratified the
transaction just say
we're going to fork this blockchain
we're going to have two copies one in
which the transaction didn't happen
one in which it did happen or just say
we're going to reverse out that
transaction we're going to we're going
to change this blockchain
so what happened is there were there
were two forks
one in which it got changed one in which
it didn't so there was some set of
people who said
we're going to just follow the
computational law and we're going to
just say
we're you know this person could do this
that was what the code said
let them do it and the other group said
no we're going to take some sort of
overarching human control of this
and we're going to say we're going to
back out that transaction so i haven't
looked recently but but last time i
looked
the the one where people backed out the
transaction was worth 10 times more
than the one where they hadn't and um
the uh
and so that was kind of a lesson of
at some level it's actually a good idea
to have humans in the loop
and that's really the question of
whether you know that that's that's sort
of a
a proof of the value of governments or
something in that case now you can say
the government's going to do the wrong
thing i don't like that government
you know one of the things about the
world today is there are a couple of
hundred countries in the world
it's not the case that there's just one
government i mean to me that's a
that you know if you have just one
government it's going to be the perfect
government
it's going to do exactly the right thing
under all circumstances what that means
who knows
because it's always going to be the case
that there's you know the government's
going to do the perfect thing but it's
not going to be the perfect thing for
everybody
it might be the perfect thing for 90 of
the population but 10
is very unhappy might be the perfect
thing for 51
of the population but 49 is very unhappy
it's it's not really possible to solve
that problem that's kind of the
the fundamental problem of political
philosophy or something is that you
can't
you know with with if you are having
these central
decisions you can't make decisions which
are going to make everybody happy all of
the time
and and so you know the thing that's
happened in the world among other things
is we have a couple of hundred countries
and so that at least gives even though
there's not
complete flexibility to like move from
one country to another or whatever
that at least gives some possibility of
the world not being this very fragile
place
where it's kind of like there's just one
thing if we make a mistake
if we you know if if there's a bug in
our computational constitution
that determines how our our you know one
world
you know country works then everything's
toast
you know the world doesn't isn't set up
that way and it's probably for the
better now you know the question of why
there are 200 countries
can we explain why they're 200 countries
rather than a thousand countries
or rather than 18 countries i don't
think that's easy to explain
i think in the past one could have said
it's sort of geographical countries are
you know based on actual borders and to
some extent that's still true
but there's also a question of why did
countries not fragment into
smaller pieces there's some value to
having a bigger country
there's some value to having you know to
having everybody who is
kind of really likes this thing make
their own country
and make it separate from some other
country and that's you know a
complicated thing that happens in the
world
that uh you can kind of look with as a
we we have the data
of language of of sort of all the
historical country borders
um throughout recorded time there are
about four thousand sort of
distinct country-like things that have
existed in the course of human history
that we know about
and you can kind of see you can make an
animation of how those country borders
move over the course of time
it's really it's kind of shocking
because it looks so much like some kind
of process that's happening in
in physics or biology or something like
that things will get bigger and
and they'll split and then something
will get really really big you know some
giant empire and then pop
you know suddenly it disappears and
there's none of it anymore and it looks
like a very kind of physical process it
doesn't look like a process
where on the ground that was humans
doing you know huge amounts of effort
and
and having wars and fighting and and
agreeing on things and so on and so on
and so on
it just looks like some physical process
that could be taking place with a bunch
of uh
microorganisms or or things in just
purely in physics
so it's kind of a weird thing but but
that's um
and i don't really know how to think
about sort of this process of countries
breaking apart countries
uh you know combining together the
different forces that cause those
different things to happen
it would be quite interesting if there
was sort of a way to say oh if there are
seven billion people there are going to
be 200 countries
you might have thought given that there
are a lot more people in the world today
that there will be more countries in the
world today than they were in the past
they're actually probably slightly fewer
than they were in the past
and that's probably a trade-off between
number of people mechanisms of
communication
the kind of cost of having a country you
know the the
if you have a country well you have to
have your postal service work
you have to agree on you know what's
going to happen with your satellite in
you know with your internet
fiber optic cables you know there's a
certain sort of set of infrastructure
that you need to agree on
to sort of have to stand up a country
you know you have to say we're going to
be members of
this treaty and that treaty and so on so
i think it becomes
it's probably a little bit more
difficult to kind of stand up your own
country at this point
than it was in the past but but you know
i think that's a um
but you know the question was um is is
you know
uh is it sort of cryptocurrencies
against the government well i think to
some extent it is
and i think this is one of these things
that's complicated because
it's you know it's part of the sort of
trade-off of you know if a government
tries to say we're really
in control we're going to control
everything people get upset and say we
don't want that
and then they sort of push back and say
we're going to invent these things that
sort of go around the government
if the government is like oh we're not
doing anything we're just hands off
and and then you know terrible things
happen and people say
hey government you should have been you
know paying attention to this
doing something about this you know you
know you should have been going and
making sure that other country didn't
didn't
uh uh you know attack us or whatever you
should be making sure that this or that
thing
uh you know happens and then people say
we you know we we want the government to
do more stuff
and then so it's you know it's it's a
complicated trade-off which
i don't think ends in any particularly
uh uh clear way i think
the thing that is interesting to think
about now and maybe this is a
complicated topic for this venue but but
um is given that we have kind of the
idea of computation
how can we change sort of the processes
of government
and uh you know the fact that we could
have democracies
that work with people having votes and
putting them on pieces of paper or
however they do them
and you know it depends on for example
the fact that people
can uh you know get to a place to vote
that you can move the votes to a central
place that you can
combine them that people can read at
least enough or can be literate
at least enough to have some idea what
they're voting for and and be able to
you know fill things out and so on
and the question is if we have a world
where everything is computational
and where even people are
computationally literate how does that
change what's conceivable
in terms of the the management of of the
world so to speak
you know right now democracy is sort of
somewhat enabled by
communication literacy things like that
what is enabled by kind of computational
literacy
what is enabled by the things that we
can do computationally today
and i've thought a bit about this and
there are certainly things one can
imagine
as kind of thought experiment some of
which don't end well i mean one is
instead of saying i vote for a b and c
you say i'm going to write a
computational essay which defines in
computational language
what i want to be true about the world
and then you take
you know 100 million of those things or
a million of those things you combine
them all together
and then you have this big ai program
that says given all these things that
all these different people want
here's the way to best achieve whatever
best achieve means
the things that people say in their
computational essays
unfortunately to do that you run into
exactly the same problems of political
philosophy that you run into in all
these other places
where it's like well what are you really
trying to achieve is it like 90
to happy even if 10 are very unhappy
what are you trying to achieve how does
how do you kind of make that landscape
of who's happy who's not happy
based on these complicated computational
essays but you get a lot more
sort of fine control of things by doing
that than you do by just saying i elect
so and so to go represent me another
thing that's true
is that in in sort of this this world
you could you can imagine something
where you would even say
so the feedback mechanism oh gosh you
know you voted for this
you put this in your computational essay
whatever you know you can get an alert
on your phone that says
this thing just happened in the world
that can be traced back as a consequence
of this thing that you voted about two
years ago and so that's something we
don't have right now i mean people just
say
i vote for this okay so and so you know
i get this person as
as you know in this political position
and then it's like okay
and they do what they do and and you
know things happen
but there's very little feedback you
know until the next election comes up
and people say
oh that person did a terrible job oh
that person did a great job whatever it
is
um it's uh uh you know it'd be kind of
interesting if you could see in a micro
microscopic level oh you know this thing
just happened in the world
and that was a consequence of the thing
that i voted for
you know two years ago and so on and
that would give people a kind of
feedback they don't have right now
now whether that's you know many people
just say i don't care i don't want to be
you know i'm not in the business of
running the country i'm just doing my
thing
you know let's let somebody else go
around the country um
and uh i think that that but but you
know there are things one can imagine
doing and i i certainly haven't figured
them all out
um i've been sort of meaning to think
about this at some point of sort of the
computational democracy so to speak what
does it look like what are the new
possibilities
for sort of the governance of a country
that are made possible by the existence
of sort of
computational computational contracts
computational assays
those those kinds of things
um oh boy there's specific questions
about what do i think about china's uh
digital currency
you know it's it's always interesting um
oh pamela disaster is that what caused
the ethereum hard fork yes the answer is
yes
the um the uh um
uh you know it's always very complicated
to um
uh
you know i don't know i i probably get
myself too deep into politics to talk
about which i don't want to do
to talk about kind of the the
relationship between sort of
uh the you know what people actually do
what people say they're going to do
what um uh it's a it's a
it's always a it's a funny thing because
we as a species so to speak
we respond a lot to stories that get
told
you know the narratives the the kind of
the the marketing message about what's
going on
is often very important to to what
people decide to do
and even people will say that was the
right thing
even though something very bad happened
if this sort of the marketing message
was right
so it gets really complicated
disentangle kind of
what is uh you know what's the message
versus what's reality versus what was
the consequence of this
versus could anybody have known what the
consequence was going to be
can you blame somebody for that because
they knew what the consequence was going
to be
and so on and you know i think that um
uh you know one of the things that tends
to happen is
there's sort of often a trade-off of you
know do you want the government to be
like doing a lot of stuff or do you want
them to just be
like just try and keep everything
running smoothly and don't
don't interfere too much and then it's
kind of like well well something's wrong
with society
so therefore we have to move some lever
to try and make it
go in a different direction well
sometimes it's very hard to predict what
moving that lever is actually going to
do
and sometimes the consequence will be
some disastrous thing in some direction
which was very very hard to foresee and
sometimes the kind of
you know a lot of ethical questions uh
end up with
well there's a level you can see and
there's a consequence you can't see
and you tend to people tend to pick you
know
you know let's let's even though we have
certain chances that things we can't see
will be disastrous
we'll pick doing the thing we can see
because because
that seems like the right thing to do
even though at a
sort of deeper rational level you can
kind of see it's probably not the right
thing to do
so there are lots of kinds of complexity
there which i certainly
wouldn't claim to understand and i think
the only thing that i think i do have
some understanding of is is
this phenomenon that you know people
sometimes have said
look we can just if we use if we have
enough science
we can make a perfect government we can
just make everything run perfectly
we just use science and everything will
work we can calculate everything we can
calculate
how the economy should work we can
calculate how you know all these
different systems should work and we
just
just use science and all be well well
the thing that i uh and you know that's
a phenomenon that's sort of grown over
the last 500 years or so
of the the just used science um uh
phenomenon
and i think that the um uh that um
uh that that mechanism of um so one of
the things that i've realized as a
result of science i've done
is that there's this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility
even though you know the scientific
rules by which something may
work at a small scale you can't predict
what the sort of what the many
iterations of that rule will do and so
and that's a phenomenon that is not to
do with us being kind of
you know stupider than we should be so
to speak it's a fundamental phenomenon
about the way that science and
mathematics work but there is this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility
that even when you know the underlying
rules you can't foresee the outcome
sort of more efficiently than just
running the system to see
what it does and so that's a case in
which sort of science
is is showing its its its limitations
from inside science that's not something
coming from outside science
and saying oh science is all nonsense we
really know what's true from some
other kind of uh you know spiritual
belief type thing or some other thing
it's not something like that um it's
simply saying that from within
science we know there are limitations to
science
and so so from that point of view uh one
can kind of realize that these things
where people say
we'll just use science to decide what to
do well that's just not going to work
in the end there's going to be what we
would call a judgment call
it's going to be something where we
can't know what's going to happen we
just have to say we're going to do this
even though it might be wrong because
you've got to decide something and it's
sort of a judgment call you can say
well i'm going to weigh these factors
and these factors but you'll never get
it perfectly right
and however good the science is it's
never going to be able to decide the
answer
so it's not you know we can't just say
let's abdicate human responsibility
and just say let the science decide
because it can't it's simply it's
limited from within itself
about what it can say and i think that's
an important thing to realize which
you know i don't know i've been talking
about computational irreducibility
for about true what is it now um 35
years or so
and there's a slow you know in in in
some areas of science it's it's decently
well understood at this point
but i think in in the world at large
it's only slowly beginning to be
understood
and people are still on this idea that
kind of started 500 years ago with folks
like copernicus and so on
that that it's kind of like we've got
science
it's going to solve everything for us uh
you know don't worry
if the scientists get far enough they
will be able to solve everything it's
just not going to happen that way it
cannot happen that way
it is a fundamental feature of the
structure of science itself
that has those limitations and it's not
a phenomenon of our inadequacy with our
brains our computers anything else
it's just a consequence of well it's
really a consequence of this thing i
call the principle of computational
equivalence
it's a consequence to the fact that our
brains are no more computationally able
than these systems we're studying and so
that means that we're never going to be
able to sort of outrun those systems
um so that's a that's a place where sort
of the can we make a perfect government
or something
the answer is no just as we can't make
sort of a perfect
legal system which has no weird weird
sort of cases
that sort of have to be decided by
judgment so to speak
so i think that that's um uh the um
uh yeah somebody's commenting doctor
doom good good
good uh good name for this comment
concept for democracy ai makes for a
great science fiction novel
but horrifying when applied to real life
well yes um
i mean it you know it's a complicated
thing because
there are features where people will say
oh
it's fairer to have an algorithm just
decide
yeah i mean to some extent but it's you
know in the end
thing in the end there is no right
answer so
the algorithm will implement some answer
that it is
basically you know it'll implement
certain kinds of constraints
it'll it will have features that you
can't readily predict
but you can implement certain kinds of
things um
the uh um it's um
it's it's something where um uh
you know yeah in the end
it's some uh you know the giant ai that
just
decides what to do for the good of
everybody it's not a possible thing
um and uh uh yeah
it's some anyway let me see so
gosh that was a long long answer that a
few other questions here
um
boy there's a question from
[Music]
something is finding the shortest proof
of the theorem computationally
irreducible
uh yes that's an example of something
that has this phenomenon
it's it's a sort of classic example
actually of of that
of that feature um
ah let's see
boy there are a lot of interesting
questions here well um
let's see
it's a question here from i think nick
if you were sent into the past with one
object of your choice with no return
what would you do to speed up human
progress
it has to be a computer that that's
um i think a computer with all of the
knowledge that we have on
on a modern computer that's um that's
almost cheating because it's almost like
saying
i'm taking a software version of all of
uh a modern technology now how i get to
power my computer
that's an interesting question i think
i'd have to have some kind of um
uh you know solar thing or something
that i can
can hand crank or some such other thing
i mean i i've sometimes thought it's
sort of a fun question
if you took a computer you know take
your laptop and you show it you take it
back a few hundred years and you show it
to people
and you say you you wonder what on earth
do they think this thing actually
is i was thinking one day i've been
thinking about this for decades and it's
one of these things i should eventually
get around to
just for fun writing a little little
book of of kind of
fictional dialogues with sort of uh
thinkers of the past
uh which kind of launched by i've got a
laptop here it is
and they're like what is this thing and
it's like you could imagine
like pythagoras you know 500 bc roughly
um you know pythagoras looking at this
laptop
what the heck is it you know it's doing
all these things
i think that that probably his view
would be
that the laptop is some kind of
disembodied human souls
you know it's kind of like all this
stuff is happening somehow in this box
you have disembodied human souls now
what's interesting about that point of
view and i'm sort of just
back projecting by 2 500 years so who
knows whether that's actually what would
be concluded
but it's kind of like you know is that a
reasonable model for what's going on
this is and then you might ask well
whose human souls are they you know
souls
are associated with a person you know
these these disembodied
uh instances of of sort of things
happening of
thought you know they must be associated
with a person whose are they
well you know there are programmers
there are people who created
you know this computational knowledge et
cetera et cetera et cetera in a sense
this is a repository of you know of
of some version some sort of shadow of
their
kind of soul so to speak and that's one
point of view but it's kind of
interesting to see at different times in
history
what would people think you know what
would newton think
a modern laptop was you know some kind
of weird
chemical process type thing of
perhaps of producing you know all these
chemical things some kind of
alchemical thing i'm not sure um it's
interesting to see what will be the kind
of cognitive model
of um of what's happening in a modern
sort of uh you know in a modern laptop
so to speak
and then and then how would that you
know given that
what is the actual mechanism by which
you generate
you know what would what would
accelerate human progress what artifact
from today would have accelerated human
progress in the past
and then you know i view my personal
activity in some sense is creating
artifacts from the future
and delivering them today so it's kind
of like
when we build out this you know
computational language or something
we're creating things which i kind of
think rather perhaps arrogantly
that um you know if left to its own
devices the world might invent these
things in a hundred years
and you know my my personal sort of uh i
don't know
feeling importantness comes from the
fact that maybe i can
bring those things that would have
naturally been invented 100 years from
now
and invent them now um and uh and
deliver them to the world now
but there's sort of a big question of if
you have a an artifact from the future
and uh you know this question posed the
the if you could take something from
today and take it back
to to some number of hundreds of years
in the past
what um uh you know given that you have
an artifact from the future
how would you use that to change the
world so to speak how would you use that
to pull the world towards that future
um if that's you know not a it's not the
case that at every time in history
people have actually been interested in
being
pulled towards the future i mean today
we still have the point of view that the
future is good
i'm not sure that people always have had
that point of view sometimes people had
the point of view
the past was good i mean you know for
what 1500 years
people were using the infrastructure
that was built by the roman empire
and it looked like the past was pretty
good we don't know how to build all
these fancy stone buildings and
aqueducts and all those kinds of things
we don't have the organization to build
them today so it looked like things were
really pretty good in the past and not
close the future is better
but in today's world we have the point
of view you know the future looks pretty
bright
and and so from that point of view it's
like okay you're put back in some time
in history
you got your laptop it's got all kinds
of information on it what do you do
um and and how do you actually you know
what what is the mechanism
of taking that sort of uh knowledge and
and you know
that spot of knowledge so to speak and
diffusing it in the world i have to
admit that that's
that's a little bit the problem i
sometimes feel and some of the things
that we do when we build technology
uh when you know technology i built for
example it's like we built this great
technology
and now we have to diffuse it out into
the world we have to essentially get the
world to know what we've done and
and sort of absorb it and and same is
true with scientific ideas
it's often not very easy to do that it's
often a very complicated
long you know arduous process to do that
and sometimes it's it's something where
you it's not it's not the work of one
person to do that because it's something
that ultimately
has to be diffused across kind of the
the knowledge and beliefs of a large
number of people
so it's kind of a challenging thing it's
kind of almost like you go back in
history with one
technological artifact and it's like you
have to
you have to start a whole giant movement
you have to become
you know a a political leader or
something to be able to get anything to
happen with that amazing technological
artifact
that you've delivered back into the you
know from the future that you delivered
into the past
so i guess i i guess as i think about it
i'm a little bit pessimistic of you know
one person one laptop or whatever uh you
know what
um what would you get to um to show from
that
and it's kind of like well you could
imagine you know you say well let's take
back a rocket or something let's take
back a
a fancy airplane of course you have to
have the infrastructure to operate the
thing
but even you could do that so what i
mean you know you've got a big
airplane and people say well we can see
birds and what is this thing that's a
really weird thing
who cares you know and and then you
maybe you start the giant
cult of the airplane but um that that's
that's then a complicated human
organization thing
that has little to do with the piece of
technology that you brought back i mean
maybe
maybe you get to sort of uh uh you know
act like something that that is um uh
you know
it's kind of like this is this is the
amazing super wizard human type thing
um and everybody should pay attention to
them because they have this piece of
technology
look they have this piece of technology
therefore but but it becomes a very
different problem it becomes a
can you lead the people to do something
reasonable rather than you have this
piece of technology now now obviously
there are things where for example to
build a laptop there's a huge
layer of infrastructure of you know you
have to have the precision manufacturing
the you know creating the crystalline
silicon to make the chip
you know creating all of these you know
having all this infrastructure
of mining different materials to use for
this and that and the other
setting up all this uh kind of precise
uh machinery which was built from many
generations of other precise machinery
and so on there's a huge
amount of infrastructure necessary to
create a laptop
and if you bring back a laptop you don't
get to bring back the infrastructure to
create laptops
i mean perhaps sometime in the future we
will have closer to self-replicating
machines
where where it will be enough to just
bring back one of those machines just
like
you know we have very good in in living
systems you know we have that they've
solved the problem of making a molecular
scale
thing that replicates itself we haven't
solved that for technology we can't do
that
kind of on demand for technology so i
don't have great answers it's a really
interesting question
um all right let's see
uh
there's a question from kelly asking
about some genetic reprogramming to
reverse aging
and um uh what am i doing because i'm an
ancient character by now to uh extend my
life so far not a hell of a lot
i i pay a lot of attention and paid
attention for decades to those kinds of
things
but really it's just like um uh do the
obvious
things and don't um i i've not um
uh i haven't um um uh
you know i i haven't uh i haven't
figured out
or become convinced enough to see you
know some particular
uh you know obscure kind of take this
chemical
to to live longer type thing um
there's a question from um i see here
do i have a spikey one of our uh well
from spikies on top of
our christmas tree um we've often had
that i have not
noticed i have to admit this year
um i would say the likelihood is high
they're very convenient
um christmas tree toppings because
they're they're cardboard you assemble
them
they assemble them in in 12 panels
and if you leave out one of the panels
you can stick the top of the christmas
tree
through that um so that that works well
all right maybe one or two more
questions here and then we should wrap
up
um
let's see
um
it's a question for permanently i know
any of the people involved in designing
the ada programming language
um i don't believe that i
did that was a it was a you know there
was an attempt
so there are different kinds of
programming languages and
there was an attempt in the early 1980s
by the u.s department of defense to
create a standard programming language
that everybody would use unfortunately
as is often the case when there's a
committee designing something it got
very very very very complicated it got
so complicated i'm not sure it was ever
even implemented
i think it's one of the languages that
was designed by a committee very few of
the languages
in fact i can't think of any language
that became popular was designed by a
committee
there was another one from much earlier
in the history of computing algol
in the early 60s which was also designed
by committee also got kind of
complicated also was never implemented
had a bunch of ideas that we used for
other languages was never fully
implemented
i believe aida had the same situation i
don't think it was fully implemented
and i think what ended up happening was
the you know one of these things that's
sort of terrible about the way that
people set up rules and then
people figure out how to game those
rules is you know the department of
defense said all our code has to be
written in ada
and then people started writing
converters that would convert
from c and fortran and so on to ada and
of course the code that they produced
when it was automatically converted from
this to that was absolutely horrible
code that nobody could possibly read
so the idea of having this ada language
was everybody will make a common
language that everybody can read
the actuality was most of the ada code
insofar as there was any ada code that
was created was created
automatically from other languages and
almost completely unreadable
so it was it was not a successful idea
um
let's see pomenties is commenting on my
my comments from uh about pythagoras
just tell pythagoras that the computer
just runs completely on numbers
then he would be very happy well that's
that's
not a bad not a bad strategy i i mean i
think you know
what to me would be a satisfactory
explanation of how something works
is very different from what would be a
satisfactory explanation to pythagoras
i mean if you look at what pythagoras
talked about
it's things like you know he had a very
definite uh kind of
social meaning for different numbers
like a one meant
i don't remember what one meant but but
you know there was a there was a number
for uh i don't know men versus women
versus happiness versus unhappiness i
don't really remember
um but uh and he was very very amazed by
this thing of the tetractis
the fact that one plus two plus three
plus four
am i getting this wrong yeah equals
equals ten um he was very
very keen on that fact and it's like to
today we're like who cares that's just a
random fact about numbers
um it's so but he thought that was very
significant
and and so some of the things that he
would think of as an explanation
are just utterly different from what we
would think of as an explanation it's a
fair point i mean you might just say
the computer runs with numbers and that
might be okay great now i understand how
it works
um even though to us today that would be
a quite inadequate explanation for most
purposes
i mean it's interesting question if you
look at um young kids for example
and you say what counts as an adequate
explanation of something
and it's sort of an interesting question
but what as you go through different
sort of stages of things you know
at what point is it do you ask for what
level of explanation
and uh you know at what point do people
in general just sort of say
well why does this happen i know maybe
it's a medical thing or whatever
why does this happen or we can drill a
couple of levels down and this is why
and then we don't know any further but
some people will be quite happy
with well we drilled a couple levels
down so now we know why
even though there's still a big piece of
sort of bedrock there that you don't
know why
that's the case and i suppose in in my
own efforts to sort of find a
fundamental theory of physics
we're kind of trying to go all the way
we're trying to say
let's see if we can get all the way down
to the sort of ultimate machine code of
the universe
to understand sort of in some sense
what's happening even if we can't
necessarily because of computational
irreducibility
we can't make all the connections all
the way up to things we say
today um
well let's see maybe one more here um
uh let's see there's a question from
mikhail about formal proofs about
computational irreducibility
that's a complicated story there are
particular cases in which one can give
formal proofs
but the general concept is more general
than any of those proofs
and it's the same kind of thing as the
concept of for example heat in
thermodynamics
has the same feature when you try and
nail it down you can nail down certain
aspects of it
but there always will be things where
there's a useful intuitive notion
which is a bit bigger than the things
that you can fully nail down
and it's the same thing with
computational irreducibility as a guide
to intuition it's a bit bigger
than any of the sort of specific slices
of it that you can nail down but you can
nail down
specific slices and quite big ones um
let's see
oh boy there's a question here right
that's two more and then then we wrap
for today
uh question here from saku
ushiba um is it possible to make a wire
from space to to earth and pull things
up to space
you know this has been a long running
question that people um
it's often called the space elevator
idea you know you have a satellite
okay first point is you have a satellite
it's orbiting the earth
if you're in low earth orbit you go
around the earth every 90 minutes
so if you have a satellite orbiting the
earth and it's going around every 90
minutes
if you've got a wire connecting the
satellite to the earth that wire is
going to get awfully tangled up awfully
quickly
but it is possible if you go further
away from the earth
the time to go around one orbit gets
longer
and about 24 000 miles above the equator
of the earth
um you you actually it's a 24-hour
uh orbital period so that means that
things that are
orbiting well for example above the
equator doesn't matter
where it is but it's more useful above
the equator um
things that are orbiting above the
equator at 24 000 miles out
will go round the earth once every 24
hours
and that means that the earth turns and
the satellite moves
and it always stays at the same place
relative to the earth so that's how
if you look at the positions of
satellites in earth orbit um
the uh there are there's a giant
collection of satellites in
geostationary orbit
um in in this orbit 24 000 miles above
the equator there's a big sort of ring
around the earth you might say
you know oh we have saturn and has a
ring you know of which is just little
rocks and so on
the earth has a ring too it's made of
satellites that are in that particular
location above the earth which has the
feature that
if you're a satellite that's beaming
television programs for example
to let's say you know north america you
can just sit at that one place
above the equator and as the earth turns
you go around the earth at the same
speed that the earth turns
and so you always stay above the same
point in the equator that's why for
example if you have a satellite dish
you have a satellite dish that doesn't
move which most don't
then you'll point it in a direction
that's looking 24
000 miles above the above the equator
looking if you're in north america
towards the south
um and uh it'll be pointing at a
satellite that's sitting above the
equator
so okay so you can have a geostationary
satellite so then you say well what if
we just put a wire
that connects the geostationary
satellite to
um to the earth you know we just have
this wire that connects
the satellite to the earth and then
maybe we just have something
which crawls along the wire it just has
a you know wheels or something
and it just runs itself along the wire
to go from earth
from the surface of the earth into orbit
okay
can that work okay big bug is there is
no material
strong enough to even maintain its own
weight
getting on that long a piece of wire
it's like having a suspension bridge
and the suspension bridge is 24 000
miles long
and there isn't a known material that is
that strong now there is some hope
that things like carbon nanotubes um
these kind of molecular scale
uh materials made from the sort of new
arrangement of carbon
might conceivably be knitted together to
be strong enough to make
a kind of a cable that could be 24 000
miles long
and and go from the surface of the earth
into into geostationary orbit
and and so that's that's the main issues
you can't make something that's strong
enough to
to have that to create that kind of wire
that you can then sort of crawl along
but it's not obvious that there can be
no material strong enough there's no
there's no sort of proof that it's not
possible to make a material that's that
strong
it's just a question of people finding a
material that's that strong
and probably probably it will require
creating a material
sort of from scratch you know creating
the the atomic structure
to make something that's strong we don't
really know how to do it
i mean there are a lot of funky ideas
about how to get things into orbit
another one that was popular for a while
was you just shoot it from a big gun
so to speak rather than having a rocket
that has its own fuel
where your where the rocket fuel is
causing gas to be ejected from the
bottom of the rocket
at very high speed and pushing the
rocket forward instead just have
something where you have like a rail gun
where you have something where you have
the thing in the gun so to speak
and and the the the uh the either
magnetic or
or chemical uh process is just making
something go really really fast
in this gun and and then out into fast
enough
that you know like 17 000 miles an hour
orbit insertion speed or whatever
um and uh to to sort of zoom out to
orbit
i mean there's another idea there's a
company actually that's trying to make
something
which just spins things around really
really really fast
and then it spins them spins them really
fast and then it just
sort of opens a little door and lets the
thing go and it's spinning so fast that
it just sort of
goes fast enough to get into orbit we'll
see whether that works out
it's kind of an interesting thing
because if you're spinning something
around
you can be spinning it around in a
vacuum where there's no air resistance
and it's only when that little sort of
door opens that that you get
um then you have to time things exactly
right to get it to kind of
exit the spinning area at the right
moment to be able to get into orbit
um we'll see
there's a question here um uh from
trevoid what will math look like in a
thousand years
it's a good question i think the um uh
maybe i shouldn't address that here but
but the i've thought quite a bit about
what the kind of
limiting structure of mathematics is in
math
the things we learn we learn all kinds
of facts about numbers you know we learn
that
the prime numbers have this particular
pattern we learn that this particular
thing based on prime numbers and
pairs of prime numbers and this and that
and the other works in this particular
way
we learn a series of facts in
mathematics and over the course of the
last you know many hundreds of years
we've learned many different facts about
mathematics when people write them down
they're about three million kind of
theorems that people write down about
facts that are true about mathematics
people written down in all the kind of
research papers and books and so on
about mathematics so far but there are
an infinite number of possible theorems
about mathematics
but the real question is kind of not
what theorems are possible there's an
infinite number
and we can have a computer to just start
enumerating them
but the question is which ones do we
humans actually care about
so for example it's just like saying
we can go and look at all possible
computations we can go and look at
all possible chemicals we can go and
look at lots of all possible things
but the question is which chemicals
which computations whatever
are relevant for us humans you know we
can imagine just an image a picture
we can imagine a picture where every
pixel of the picture is chosen at random
is that picture useful probably not
terribly useful you know if it's a
picture that's a wonderful picture of a
of a cat or something we say that's an
interesting picture but if
if we just pick those pixels by some
other algorithm
that is that makes the pixels look
completely random to us we just say
that's who knows that's just a bunch of
random pixels
doesn't seem significant to us so the
real question is not
what is conceivable in terms of the
theorems of mathematics as an infinite
number
of true theorems of mathematics the
question is which theorems are ones that
we humans are going to care about
and and that's the more difficult
question to answer and i think that
what's what we've seen happen
in the history of mathematics we've been
steadily building out these kind of
different paths where we build we build
we build and we build more stuff on that
path more stuff on that path and so on
and that's been what's been happening
and and what's happened is often those
pods that we build out
we get to a certain point and we realize
gosh that's really really useful for
lots of things we want to do maybe we
build
technology that way maybe we build some
cryptographic system that way maybe we
build some other
you know compression algorithm that way
maybe we do something else that way
so then then a whole bunch of stuff in
our world starts working according to
that kind
of mathematics and then that's becomes
the big sort of area
that we then build from and build on and
build more stuff and so on
and so that that's some you know that
seems to be a typical kind of thing that
happens
and so if you ask what's mathematics
going to look like in a thousand years
it's uh uh well there's a lot of
questions about sort of the
the future of our civilization and so on
and and the future of sort of pure
biological organisms versus
computational kinds of things let's put
those aside let's assume that we're
we're just dealing with um uh you know
history that that
uh goes into the future much as it's
gone in the past of just
you know humans living out their
generations in the way that they do
um you know what happens to something
like mathematics in that situation
and i think the answer is you build in
all these different paths
and it's like the evolution of of
technology human language and so on
there are sort of new types of things
that get created
um and uh you know what are the
qualitatively different types of things
you know the
the major uh sort of uh cambrian
explosions of technology
the sort of cambrian explosions of
mathematics the times when just a huge
amount gets discovered or invented in
mathematics
because of some new mythological idea
and they're definitely
ones of those in the future i think we
can see some already i mean i think i
know a few
that are sort of coming in the next few
decades perhaps
um there are some uh well some to do
with
with experimental mathematics something
to do with kind of a
a global theory of meta mathematics the
global theory
of the structure of all possible
theorems um i mean i have a bunch of
ideas about using things that we've
learned
from our physics project to be able to
sort of map out
the geometry of the of the set of all
possible theorems and how they connect
to each other
it's kind of like it's a trade-off
between it's like geometry and geography
like we can know the shape of the
structure of the surface of the earth
it's roughly a sphere
that's of the geometry of the earth but
there's the geography which is
you know where do we actually choose to
put our cities where do we actually
populate on the earth and it's the same
thing in mathematics
we can we can right now we've been just
sort of geographically populating
different parts of mathematical space
but we can imagine also working out
an overall theory for sort of the
geometry the analog of geometry for
mathematical space
and i think i have some ideas about how
to do that and i think that that will
give us some clues
about sort of what's conceivable in the
in the infinite future of mathematics
and so on
um just as we can say some things about
what's conceivable
about sort of the infinite future of
where we can geographically populate
on the earth from knowing the geometry
of the earth
you know there's a question from mark
here tell us secret
that um tech huge tech company ceos
know that that um uh i was saying
since you're a tech company ceo you
might know something crazy and secret
i'm sure i do
um and i wouldn't stay a secret if i
were to tell it to you but
but i i tend to um because we've been a
company that's been around a long time
and because i've known most of the
leaders of a good fraction of the
of what become large tech companies i
tend to know lots and lots of stuff
about what people
are thinking about and planning and so
on and uh part of the reason i know it
is because i don't tell it to people
um but uh the um
you know i think the thing um
uh his his something which isn't a
secret at all but which people seem to
think is a secret
which is you know every piece of
technology we have got invented by
somebody
and people seem to have this idea that
you know oh it's this kind of it sort of
just happens it's this sort of faceless
thing
where where um uh just some somehow you
know
big company x just makes a thing well
it's it's not that it's actually
you know people humans somebody had to
have that idea
somebody had to invent the the methods
for doing it
and uh it's always quite interesting to
trace through
um kind of you know what actually did
happen how did that idea get invented
and and for many ideas in the tech
industry well i know whether many i
i well yes for many i know the answer i
wouldn't say for most
um you know the ones where i investigate
in fact just last night a friend of mine
who's
who's a well-known person in computer
graphics world
who's writing a book about history um
sent me a link to some of the some of
the material in his book
which contains all kinds of um
uh all kinds of um um
uh information about early history of uh
of a bunch of computer graphics
some uh work was quite quite interesting
and quite a lot which i didn't know
which makes certain things that happen
make sense
but um anyway that's um it seems like i
misunderstood the question and the
question was about some
uh success in business and so on you
know i haven't been talking about
business much in
in these live streams i was uh various
people have suggested that i do some
live streams
about business um and uh i think
probably the things i tend to know about
you know i've run a company for
a third of a century now uh and and um
uh same company for a third of a century
and i've i've been involved in many
other
companies and and so on and i i guess
i've i've learned a certain amount about
business i
i i think of myself as somebody who is
mostly
a person who figures out intellectual
things um
you know i've been competent enough at
business to ceo a company for a long
time
and have the company be successful um
and i think that the um
uh there probably is a there's a lot
that i know about business
that i think is kind of obvious um but
it may not be obvious
as obvious to other people as it seems
to me to to be to me
and a lot of things about business have
to do with you know running businesses
taking advantage of opportunities uh
sort of
uh doing the right thing not getting
wound up and
you know they're also it's worth saying
there are different styles of running
businesses like for example
you know i tend to be we're going to
invent a bunch of interesting stuff
and that's the biggest priorities invent
the interesting stuff and do a good job
doing it rather than i'm going to listen
to what all the customers say
and i'm going to just follow what the
customers say even though i don't think
the customers are saying very visionary
things they're just saying
what the thing that they need to solve
the problem that they have today
not thinking about the thing they'll
need to solve the problem they have 10
years from now
but there are different styles of doing
business there are stars of doing
business
where one is really uh sort of it's all
about you know persuading the customers
to do something their styles of business
where it's all about just
making something great and explaining
why it's great and hoping the customers
will come and so on
there are lots of different styles of
doing business and uh
you know i've certainly some of them
i've followed myself
more of them i've observed in other
people sometimes i've said that's just
not going to work
and often i'm right it's just not going
to work and sometimes i'm wrong
sometimes it's like you know i just
a company like that just can't work and
then it becomes a
a you know a multi-tens of billions of
dollar company after a while
so sometimes one's wrong about those
things but um
and sometimes one says about people you
know that's a person who is definitely
going to succeed
and they don't and that's a person who
doesn't have a hope and they succeed
um so it's it's it's always quite
interesting and challenging
but um yeah i'd be happy to talk about
that at some point and i
i think um uh there's been sort of
various suggestions that i do a a
separate live stream
about um business and innovation and i
think we're probably going to try and
start that
in the new year and that will be a good
venue to to ask lots of kinds of
questions and i
you know one of the things that's
challenging about that is is
my first interpretation of this question
about about secrets it's like i could
tell you a lot of stories about
about our own company about other
companies about our interactions with
other companies and so on
and um uh it's it's uh you know at some
point
it becomes possible to tell those
stories because so much time has passed
that there's nothing sort of sensitive
in those stories anymore but
um uh it's uh you know that there's a um
uh it's sort of challenging to know at
what point things passed into history
and at what point
you know oh there was this person and
they had this crazy idea
and then it you know it turned out was
crazy and they got this to happen and
that to happen
and it's like at what point does that
count as being sort of just history
and at what point do you feel like those
are stories that you shouldn't tell
and i don't completely know the answer
to that and um that's that's one of the
sort of challenges
um in in these things but anyway so for
for another thing probably for the new
year um
a uh another set of live streams
about kind of um uh uh
business and innovation and so on um
probably aimed mostly at young
entrepreneurs
um and uh uh trying to pass on
what wisdom i have although with the
with the important caveat that
uh you know there are an infinite number
of ways to succeed probably like the
like the theorems and mathematics so to
speak and um you know i can i can talk
about ones that i've seen
and ones that i've seen didn't work um
but uh that doesn't mean that there
aren't others that that
that can work all right well
uh we should wrap it up here and um
not sure if we're doing one of these um
next week we might
um and um well
thanks for thanks for joining us and uh
see you another time